video showing a father and his son
carrying her body out of their home two
years ago right now that son is on the
run his father out of jail the 8 news
now i-team's david charns here now with
why
brian denise a spokesperson for metro
police which of course operates the jail
telling me jose rangel received credit
for programs he completed during what
was supposed to be a two-year sentence
tonight an attorney for the family says
it wasn't until i called her today that
they knew he was out of jail after just
eight months
chilling video of 22 year old leslie
palacio's final moments caught on
surveillance video in august 2020 jose
rangel and his son eric rengalabara
carrying her lifeless body into rengella
barra's truck he drives off and his
father then hoses off the driveway i
felt like my life has fallen apart
rangel took a plea deal for helping his
son move palacio's body last year a
judge sentencing him to two years with
credit for time served but the eight
news now i-team confirming friday rengel
was out of prison by the end of this
april eight months 15 days served of a
520 day sentence absolutely furious this
is just
unfair ophelia marcarion is the palacio
family attorney not only is the main
suspect not in custody
but now somebody who was involved who
covered up a murder
is back on the streets after serving
eight months and 15 days we don't know
where he is now rangel's son eric
rangela barra wanted in palacio's murder
remains on the run police suspect he's
hiding out in mexico he's a coward he is
a monster
he needs to pay for what he did
he does not deserve
to be living a free life
and as i mentioned police do believe
eric regalibarra is in mexico where he's
been for the last two years there is a
reward for information leading to his
arrest and conviction now the credits
his father received are mandated as part
of state law i'm david charns live local
now